Thanks, Sarah.
Now, I'm here in the forest because
everything I'm about to do can be
done completely offline.
I'm going to take a closer
look at how Git works and
how you can use it to view
the history of a file.
Specifically, I'll take a look at
game.js which contains the code from
the Asteroids game you saw earlier.
Since I had been using Git to keep track
of changes while writing this code,
I can navigate to the directory where
the code is saved and type git log.
What I get is every commit
that's ever been made,
starting with the most recent.
Notice how each commit has an ID,
an author, a date, and
a message associated with it.
For now I want you to focus on
the commit message and the ID.
The message explains what has
changed since the last commit.
And the ID is sort of
like a serial number.
It uniquely identifies each commit and
let's you refer to it.
I'll scroll a bit by
pressing the down arrow so
you can see the commits with
the changes we discussed earlier.
This commit is where I switched
the control keys to use space for
movement instead of up arrow.
This one is where I fixed the typo.
And this one is where I reverted
the controls back to the way they
were before since I didn't
like the new controls.
Scrolling back up to
the more recent commits,
you can see some commits by Doug doing
things like making a iPad version of
the game, and there's also a commit by
me adding some color into the game to
make it look more interesting.
I can check what changes a commit
introduced by using the git
diff command.
Git diff is similar to the FC or diff
program you used earlier, but instead of
just comparing two files, it can compare
different versions of a file within git.
Right now I'm going to
use git diff to see the difference
between these two commits.
So first I'll copy the first
commit ID that I want, and
then I'll copy the second and
paste them both into my command here.
When I hit enter, I see the changes
made between the two commits.
If you are using macro linux,
this output looks very similar
to the diff output earlier.
All you need to notice in these lines
is that we're comparing two versions of
the file game.js and
here's the actual diff.
You'll notice that git supports
the nice feature of colorized diff.
So the black lines didn't change.
The red lines with the minus
sign were removed,
meaning they only existed
in the first version.
And the green lines with
the plus sign were added,
meaning they only existed
in the second version.
These changes should look familiar
since they're the same changes you
looked at before.
Here's the typo you found.